alors si co du sras et je serais capable
de faire du ski comme plein ou sico
grands champions descente libre et syco
paralysé maintenant qu'est-ce que tu as
ico ça ne va pas quand sicot venir
sciglio paix enfin tombé amoureux caméra
et 026 co épuisé bathory avoir donné
grosse bise caméras mais si bête revenir
voir sic au travail cet après-midi sic
au travail est beaucoup mieux
mais alors qu'est ce que c'est c'est à
transistor qui est en panne là dedans
affirmatif mais prend bathory sicot
avoir besoin recharge comme m quand m
fatigué alors des batteries dans un tel
robot en définitive c'est un un de ces
robots plus grand que ce que l'on voit
d'habitude en jouets mais à peu près la
même chose
enfin pas tout à fait disons que là
c'est pas une panne de transistors ni je
crois pas de batterie simplement il ya
une interférence c'est le propre de
l'électronique entre nos propres
émissions
ici sur le plateau avec l'électronique
et le micro ordinateur qu'il ya à la
base du robot quand et si bien que
l'ordinateur étant dans le doute
eh bien il vit mobilisent sur place le
robot ce qui lui interdit de se déplacer
mais lui permet tout de même de
s'exprimer parce que tu n'as droit de
recevoir d'ordres de personne sort de
ton maître sicot bien pour graver six
corps veillaient aussi bon en tout cas
si qu est arrivé en classe première des
états unis car tu es américain ainsi
qu'au sicot amérique ainsi qu'aux venir
états unis pour travailler à paris dans
un grand magasin dessus du printemps et
alors là j'espère que tu pourras tu
pourra fonctionner correctement qu'est
ce que tu peux faire quand compte à
batterie est en bonne forme
sic au pouvoir dans ses six co grand
danseur international cause et pas celui
ci kono mais on travaille pas arvo
travaille bien
il n'en sera pas aujourd'hui
malheureusement à cause d'une paille
dans la batterie ou d'un petit problème
qui se pose est la télécommande bloqué
car en définitive c'est quand même à
l'arrivée ça c'est un appareil tout de
même n'est pas ce qui n'est pas un
extraterrestre exactement ce n'est pas
un appareil entièrement disons autonome
entièrement automatique parce que ça
pose des problèmes d'électronique on ne
sait pas résoudre ne serait-ce que de
synthétiser notre parole et de la
reproduire c'est très complexe et hors
de portée actuellement des ordinateurs
enfin c'est déjà perfectionnement
technique et c'est déjà c'est déjà un
beau bijou d'electronica même grâce à la
télécommande
voilà tu as un beau bijou shiko shiko
pouvoir dire secret m monzie même
qu'elle serait vous aime beaucoup
d'accord et j'espère que tu aime
beaucoup françois donati aussi toujours
si mes chronos désirer bon eh bien je
désire que tu aimes françois donati que
nous retrouvons à la bourse de paris